[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia en un plebiscito histórico
chile voto por el sí para reescribir la
constitución que estaba implantada desde
los tiempos de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet el 18 de octubre de 2019
comenzó un estallido social en santiago
la capital que se prolongó por varias
semanas y se propagó por 12 de las 16
capitales de departamento el detonante
fue el alza de 30 pesos chilenos en el
pasaje del metro un trayecto que cuesta
poco más de un dólar pero que motivó a
masivos grupos de estudiantes a evadir
el pago y saltarse las registradoras
situación que se agravó aquel viernes 18
de octubre cuando varias estaciones de
metro fueron vandalizadas incendiadas y
que de acuerdo con luigi range el
presidente de la compañía los daños
ascendieron a 300 millones de dólares yo
creo que no es banal que los estudiantes
y han sido los que empezaron la rebelión
y se produce 18
de octubre
el 18 de octubre lo que hay es una
rebelión no es una protesta es una gran
rebelión a partir de entonces se puso en
descubierto el malestar social masivo
por lo caro que resulta vivir en chile
con servicios públicos como el agua la
salud la educación todos privatizados
pero lo lamentable fueron los
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
los carabineros durante el curso de las
protestas la brutalidad policial se puso
de manifiesto bajo la ley de seguridad
del estado de acuerdo con un informe el
instituto nacional de derechos humanos
de chile en cuatro meses de protestas
murieron 34 personas varias de ellas
bajo custodia policial
más de 3700 personas resultaron heridas
en su mayoría por disparos de perdigones
otra cifra es la de 445 heridos oculares
de los cuales 34 perdieron el ojo y
fueron contabilizados más de 10 mil
arrestos entre los que se cuentan
aproximadamente 2000 vulneraciones entre
violaciones sexuales
y uso excesivo de la fuerza chile se
desbordaba por un precipicio de
violencia producto de la indignación
enquistada desde cuando augusto pinochet
impulsó una nueva constitución y varias
reformas económicas en su dictadura de
acuerdo con el libro reformas económicas
en chile- de ricardo ffrench-davis la
primera etapa de reformas entre 1973 y
1981 se caracterizó por la
implementación de un modelo neoliberal
en su forma de ideología más pura esto
significó masivas privatizaciones
incluyendo la de servicios que otras
sociedades amparan como un derecho
público un ejemplo fue la reforma
pensional de 1980 que implementó el
modelo de que cada individuo
capitalizaba a través de una empresa
privada todo bajo un ambiente de
represión y miedo que propagaba la
dictadura no creo que esto tenga solo
que ver con nuestra herencia dictatorial
o con el modelo neoliberal que por
supuesto que tiene ciertas
particularidades locales
evidentemente cierto la percepción de
una élite que abusa de su posición de
poder que ha secuestrado a las
instituciones es su exclusivo beneficio
todo eso por supuesto se da en un
contexto en particular pero también
refleja que un sentimiento bastante
global también en 1980 se redactó la
constitución que prevalece hasta hoy una
constitución que abriga varios
obstáculos para que desde el congreso no
se puedan transformar las políticas
públicas chilenas las reformas
económicas de pinochet lograron reducir
en los años 80 la escandalosa tasa de
hiperinflación herencia del gobierno
socialista de salvador allende también
consiguieron eliminar el déficit fiscal
sin embargo estos logros se
materializaron a expensas de un colapso
social que ahogó a chile en un desempleo
del 30 por ciento en 1982 y lo disparó
en tasas de pobreza pero después de que
el país votó en el plebiscito de 1988
por la transición de la dictadura a la
democracia
a los ojos del mundo comenzaron a ver a
chile con admiración el milagro de la
economía chilena en la década de 1990
bajo gobiernos democráticos se me dio
por cuenta de un destacado producto
interno bruto uno bastante mejor que el
del resto de economías latinoamericanas
para marcus taylor en su libro de
pinochet a la tercera vía la percepción
del éxito económico de la etapa de post
dictadura fue atribuida por
organizaciones internacionales como el
fondo monetario internacional para
defender las políticas neoliberales en
gobiernos democráticos un ejemplo es que
chile es el único país del mundo cuyo
servicio de agua potable es privatizado
pero desde el año 2006 los estudiantes
chilenos obligados a endeudarse de por
vida para costear su educación
comenzaron a protestar y cuando las
protestas llegaron a su punto de
inflexión el presidente sebastián piñera
se vio obligado a anunciar y conceder un
referendo para reescribir o no la
constitución de chile
nunca se ha hecho en chile una
constitución por la participación
ciudadana nunca se ha hecho en el mundo
una constitución paritaria yo creo que
lo que vamos a hacer ahora en chile va a
merecer la atención de muchas partes del
mundo o sea o tenemos una buena
constitución o aquí vamos derechito a la
y si alguien no se ha dado cuenta
cuando tú tienes miedo de la violencia y
ni siquiera puedes hacer el amor
ahora chile voto por el sí para
reescribir la constitución que desde
1980 bajo el miedo y la represión había
adelantado augusto pinochet un capítulo
histórico para chile que nace de la
voluntad popular y del malestar social
de un pueblo en contra de su clase
dirigente y de la minoría rica que
domina económicamente el país hasta aquí
llegamos hoy andrés suárez jaramillo
muchas gracias por compartir estas
historias que las encuentran
en france 24 punto com
[Música]